our last feature for this evening is an
Associated Press story on our beloved
City since the terrorist attacks of
September 11 2001 the NYPD has become
one of the country's most aggressive
domestic intelligence agencies it's also
been hailed as a model for policing the
post 9-11 era the biggest indicator of
its success is that there has been no
significant attack terrorist attack on
New York since but working over several
months a Washington dc-based
investigative team from The Associated
Press exposed how as this headline shows
the NYPD spies in New York the AP found
that New York's finest operates far
outside its borders and targets ethnic
communities in ways that would run afoul
of civil liberties rules if practiced by
the federal government it does so with
unprecedented help from the CIA neither
the City Council which finances the NYPD
nor the federal government which
contributes hundreds of millions of
dollars to the NYPD each year is told
exactly what's going on what we didn't
know until the AP told us was that the
NYPD had dispatched undercover agents
known as rakers into minority
neighborhoods as part of a human mapping
program they've also monitored daily
life in bookstores bars cafes and
nightclubs they've even put under
surveillance a beauty supply store that
sells chemicals that could be used for
making bombs police have also used
informants known as mosque crawlers to
monitor sermons even when there is no
evidence of wrongdoing they planted
informants among Muslim student groups
including here at Columbia but also
beyond New York to Rutgers and Yale NYPD
officials subscription eyes Imams and
gathered intelligence on cab drivers and
food cart vendors jobs often done by
Muslims the CIA which is prohibited from
spying on Americans helped build many of
these operations the AP team interviewed
more than 40 current and former NYPD and
federal officials they got documents
that show the existence of
of the demographics unit a squad of 16
officers fluent in five languages and
ordered to map ethnic communities in the
tri-state area the NYPD says the spy
unit doesn't exist now thanks to the AP
we know it's otherwise so Matt Apuzzo
and Eileen Sullivan what were to
washington DC reporters doing prowling
around New York what prompted this look
into NYPD secret surveillance operations
um yes so we didn't ever expect this
would be a series we sort of started in
kind of a weird way Adam Goldman and I
who's another member of our team had
been covering a lot of national security
stuff and we were really interested at
the end of 2010 we were doing a lot on
we're doing a project on CIA
accountability trying to figure out what
happened to the CIA officers who had
been involved in a lot of the big sort
of mishaps kidnapping her own guy sort
of Fiasco's of the previous 10 years and
in the course of doing that we just sort
of heard kind of what you were talking
about just as an aside about oh you know
in the NYPD's ranking program and these
were in the four people we're going to
go off and do interviews these are in
the moments in the interview when you're
like furiously writing the important
stuff and then like you kind of just let
him go off and say what you want and use
that as a moment to catch up like listen
to that stuff because that that's where
the good story was so we thought we were
going to write sort of one big story and
we thought it would run maybe the
beginning of 20 the Spring of 2011 Osama
bin Laden you may have read about in the
newspaper he was killed so that that
occupied a good deal of our time and
then we decided well you know we'll
we'll run one big story for the 911
anniversary and so Adam and I kind of
put that together we consulted with
Eileen who as you said in your
introduction knows more
out terrorism than any I think any other
journalist in the country and we sort of
put out one big story and the thing just
snow balled and became you know this
thing that has consumed our lives for a
year but it was yet was never planned do
you want to say something i dunno i
think i mean he handles I wasn't quite
reading the face signals man okay the
NYPD SI students know because they're
reporting out of neighborhoods around
New York the NYPD is one of the most
secretive police departments in the
country so how did you get people inside
the NYPD to talk to you and why would
they talk to you um well you know from
well so that's what we do right I mean
you get people who don't want to talk to
you to talk to you so the thing that I
think that our team does really well is
that we don't care if something's been
covered or if it's not necessarily like
an area of our expertise like we didn't
know anything about the NYPD I mean I
think I remember sitting down one of the
first things you know when we didn't
know what we were going to do I think we
sat down at Google and because because
young people today all we do is Google
right um so we sat down in Google right
and we said i typed in NYPD intelligence
site colon linkedin com and i just want
to see everybody in LinkedIn who had
mentioned NYPD intelligence and and i
came across somebody and i went tae lee
and i said hey do you know this guy
because used to work for homeland and
Eileen said yeah I know I'm and he only
worked in Intel for like five minutes
and Eileen set up a lunch and we went
there and he didn't know anything about
what the hell we were interested in but
it was great because um I'm really into
like understanding the way an
organization works because if you can
crack in orders if you can understand
the subculture that you're covering the
organizational the way it works then you
understand the way information flows and
so he was kind of a like all right well
there's this guy any answer to this guy
and this is over here and this is how
they all right well I just need to talk
to all those people
um but we go to people's houses and I am
a big believer in that if you can get
somebody in their sweatpants then you
know you've changed the dynamic so you
just knock on someone's so you knock on
a police officers door and then what um
so all right so that's not my first step
yeah that's not our first step but I
mean my point is is that if somebody's
not talking why would he we call people
in their offices and we expect them to
talk to us about stuff about what's
going on their office like the dumbest
thing of course they're gonna say I
can't talk to you about right i mean i
imagine how if anybody called you in
your office and was like I won't tell
you if he's your manager a bad manager
yeah he's sitting right there I mean so
we do that it's such a dumb thing so we
you know we reach out and we call them
only say you know hey we're working on a
story about the transformation of the
NYPD at post 9-11 which is true and
could we get a cup of coffee and a lot
said yes and some said no and for the
people we really needed and we'd go back
to him two or three times I wouldn't
talk to us yeah i mean just go to their
house and knock on the door um and none
of the door like what's the door wagon
same percent of the time they slam the
door in your face but twenty percent of
the time you have the best interview
you're gonna have so i mean i don't i
mean you you know i leave why would why
would these people talk to you I mean
you've been covering terrorism for a
long time why would people who hold
secrets about you I think I think there
are a couple of reasons and you know one
of them is that some of them are really
proud of what they've done they take a
lot of pride in protecting New York and
they get up in the morning to do this
and and they think that they've put
together this very unique domestic
intelligence program and others feel a
little uncomfortable with some of what
they're doing I mean just with
interactions with their own bosses that
you know they're bringing them
information saying we're not getting
anything and yet they're going back and
they're told you to get some more and
then I think that there's also a casing
and you can add to this but there it's
so secretive what goes on there and
there's just so much reluctance to talk
about it not just within the NYPD but
outside
particularly in Washington and I say
particular Washington because that's
where we are but nobody wants to talk
about this so now you have you know
somebody who gets up every day believes
in what he does and no one's going to
talk about it support against I mean
that was I think people wanted these
stories to get out yeah hey I think
that's right i think you know the the
lesson that i would i would say one of
the takeaways is if you if you really
throw yourself into this and and you can
see any of this i mean you threw
yourself at hey you know your photo
essay through self the data threw
yourself at the school's if you know the
institution people are going to talk to
you i mean if you don't know it and you
aren't first in it you know if you don't
know that there's 2700 methadone deaths
and you can map them well then they can
tell you you know go take a long walk
far offshore pierre like everything's
fine but if you know how the Intel
division works they it becomes a lot
harder for them to tell you no no it
works this way so why was this story
done by journalists base in Washington
DC and not by New York reporters well I
think I mean like mad explained how they
came onto the story I mean it was
through other stories that they were
working on and the expertise on
counterterrorism particularly domestic
policing was based in Washington so the
three of us even though i'm not on the
investigative team worked for the same
editor and here we had the subject
matter expertise and the bodies and the
editor and we were able to do it yeah
and i just think you know it it's a it's
an advantage of having a company in the
structure that just is a great story yet
do it and you know i think that
geographically you know we're not as
limited as probably we used to be
there's a good story we go follow it did
you get pushback from your editors about
using unnamed sources um alright so
uncovering national security ain't I'm
not on a sorcerer kind of
they kind of come with the territory
unfortunately um but this story these
kinds of story is I think what it's made
for i think i think that the awful
crappy overuse of anonymous sources
especially in Washington is appalling
and we should fight back as hard as we
can and I frankly nobody fights back
harder than I lean and but so here's the
thing so we reported that this unit that
we had all this information about the
demographics unit and the mosque
crawlers on these informant programs
we've been pushing to get an interview
with Ray Kelly and we've been pushing
again an interview with Dave Cohen who
was a former chief of clandestine
operation so the CIA who's now running
intelligence to the NYPD and we weren't
getting it so we got a phone interview
with the chief spokesman for the NYPD
and he went through all of our stuff and
denied that this existed just flout
tonight you're wrong it's fiction people
are telling you fables these are stories
is not true you're going to be
embarrassed you're going to write this
we are going to come out we're going to
say it's wrong you embarrass yourselves
etc etc so we're to go in toward into
our bureau chiefs office and say good
news we got the NYPD interview right um
uh bad news on the record denial and we
don't have just about anybody saying
anything on the record it's all
anonymous um how much do you trust us uh
um we had helps that I mean we've worked
for these editors before we've worked on
I mean when you deal with anonymous
sources you're explaining not only how
you got the information but why why your
source would be provided that
information whether this is something
that you know you need a second source
on and what does that second source I
mean if the two people were in the same
briefing I mean that's not good enough
you know I mean somebody who's in a
different briefing who's getting the
same information so we already had that
going into it they trusted us they knew
you know how we worked and they SS all
the hard questions yeah and I mean you
know we had compiled all of our
notes in these black gigantic three inch
black binders and all the clips all the
notes and um we felt pretty good about
our about our sourcing and frankly our
bureau chief never for once was like oh
they're gonna deny it maybe we sure did
you basically she's a great great let's
get that denial way up high in the store
I mean it was I mean that was such a
wonderful thing to have that kind of
support and then you know we only ended
up getting all these documents stamped
NYPD secret that proved everything we
had written was true really got that
like months later so I mean it was a
real gamble I think by our bosses to go
out on all these anonymous let me get
this right you got the documents after
you had run this to her story yet a lot
of people came forward and said thanks
yeah thanks guys uh a lot of people came
forward including people who hadn't
talked to us before and we didn't even
know existed came forward it was like oh
yeah yeah I do that that's my job and
and I mean you know we we had people who
and then and then we realized that all
we didn't know what documents were out
there we'd been asking for documents we
were getting them but once we sort of
got this tiny little trickle of
documents when we knew what to ask for
we knew what numbers they had on them
means override nobody had ever seen
anything like this and we could say do
you have a document that looks like this
and people would say yes or I can get
you that document you know and so then
it was you know like like sue said then
you're just going through all your your
master source listed like have you ever
heard of a document called this look in
your files do you have anything like
this um but yeah that first story we I
mean we put our editors in a spot where
they haven't had to say yeah we trust
you well you were also sort of in the
spot here because some readers reacted
by saying you know this is the price we
pay for our security in our safety that
some we have to give up some of our
civil liberties I mean how did you how
did you cope with this with a sort of
backlash and reaction to this series
well this has been a constant theme
since 911 and in Washington something
that I hear all the time is you don't
have to give up your privacy and civil
liberties for safety there's a balance
and
I mean a lot of what Washington was
saying to do you know telling local
police departments how to police and
engage them as I'm community was not
lining up with what New York was doing
and so you had Washington saying
something describing best practices that
New York wasn't following and all the
while I mean it seems like you're giving
up your own privacy and civil liberties
and it just it's I think we found that
it the people who are okay with it
weren't the people being spied on and I
think it history is going to tell us
sort of the effect of this down the road
I mean the next attack whoever is at
fault i mean this this model could be
replicated I think anywhere in the
country to some extent and so I just got
to say I'm so sick of 911 being used as
a way to tell reporters that they can't
report stuff I mean the number of times
that journalists get called now and say
you can't have this information because
its security you can't report what you
know because of security you know um
everybody knows everything there is to
know about the Osama bin Laden raid
right because it makes everybody look
good and um you know Jim reisen who was
probably sitting here with one of his
when he after one of his Pulitzers told
me something that really sticks with me
is that if you if you do this job
national security our investigative or
whatever you can go down the road and
have it be you you get people at the
government to tell you what they think
about other countries or what they think
about groups what they think about
organizations and then you report that
and and you can go that way and it's
really easy to go that way or you can go
the way of saying what's our government
doing often to our own citizens and
really poor reporting but the way our
government
spawns to those external factors um and
that's the only thing that interests me
so I'm I'm just sick of people telling
us because of 911 you know the press has
to has to change the way it does
business and has to be you know has to
bend over backwards we need we need a
free printer many people like this you
know here more than we've ever needed
because in I 11 or you know not going to
stop that because of my 11 okay now it's
your turn to ask questions hi my name is
Beth mekonnen and i was wondering given
how notoriously uncooperative the NYPD
are since the publication of your
stories and do you foresee new
challenges and following up on where
this goes now do you think they're going
to be even tighter about what support
information gets leaked to journalists
and what people who work at this unit
are going to be able to give to you well
I mean leaking the information to
journalists the NYPD did I they didn't
leak anything right I mean it so I think
they'll continue their leaking policy as
it fits them and miss them I mean it is
it is crazy when you I don't need to
tell you guys this you can't even get a
police report in this city right i mean
that is crazy if you told you know
twenty-one-year-old matt apuzzo who
covered a police department in a small
town that in the greatest city in the
world you couldn't get a police police
report I mean that's crazy and I mean
and I've said this a million times you
you know every journalist in the country
in this city should be standing shoulder
to shoulder and saying that's
unacceptable and you know police police
chiefs and mayors of big cities
shouldn't be able to get out of meetings
with editorial boards and interviews
with you know people who make you know
more money than you guys make and you
guys are out trying to get police
reports we should be demanding this
stuff so you're saying they couldn't be
any more stricter than they already are
yeah I mean you know try it you're right
I guess anything's possible I mean they
could put up a wall I guess I mean
around around one Police Plaza question
piece my name is Carolyn Chen um I was
wondering when you started out knowing
how ok the NYPD is how do you determine
what the minimum amount of information
you need is in order to prove your
hypothesis because it's one thing to
have a story and there's another thing
to be able to prove it and I think
sometimes the question is like what if
you couldn't get enough police officers
like how many would be enough for you to
have this story or what if you had only
partial documents but not all like when
do you say we've got enough to actually
write this a lot of frustrated NYPD
journalist in here man indeed it was at
soothe somebody said if you have the one
mistake right they'll they'll pick it
apart so I mean the number of stuff we
left on the cutting room floor because
we only had one or two people I mean you
know it's just crazy because we just
weren't we just couldn't be wrong so I
don't know there was no set number but
we went through a lot of that was what
we went through more hand-wringing on
than anything else how can we be totally
sure on that point where we couldn't be
sure we left it out or that incident if
you know if you we didn't know what you
know there were incidences were crazy
stuff happened and we knew where it
happened we do kind of squishy and when
it happened and they just said no no
we're not going to go out on a limb on
anything so high so um in addition to
opacity that NYPD has something of a
culture of lying cops get caught lying
all the time both the lowest level beat
cop to Paul Brown who speaks for the
entire department of Commissioner Kelly
as he did to you he pretty much admitted
to lying to you during the course of
your investigation how do you feel about
the impact that your investigation had
in terms of the NYPD's impunity
essentially with regards to how loose it
is with its relationship to the truth I
want Eileen to answer that question
because you know what I don't care about
the about the effect that will have on
sort of the police spokesman but I mean
Eileen was kind of our point
person on being you know really in the
communion the Muslim communities and
that's where I think we really cared
about what the impact was I don't really
care about what what Paul Broun thought
of our series and what I found is when
we would get these reports and we go to
the community and interview people and
show them their names and these police
reports I started to see this pattern of
you know people being shocked and
laughing like this ridiculous what you
know that's ridiculous why would I be in
that report what that's my friend she
runs a travel business she has kids that
they go to school of my kids that's just
crazy and I mean throughout the day at
you know hours later it gets really
upsetting you know we're in this report
because we're not doing anything at all
I mean how is that possible and so many
of these people that we interviewed are
immigrants and this is not what they
expected out of America I mean it and it
was it was really interesting to see
that and the other thing that I found
interesting is that some people when
they would see these documents said
thank you I have thought that this was
going on I thought that I've been being
spied on but no you know everyone says
no it's not going out sacco and now I
have proof I mean imagine if you have
felt for years that someone is following
you or watching you or just some like
creepiness around you and then you know
everyone's saying you're crazy that's
not what we do in America thank you you
know that people felt but then the next
thing is well now what do we do about it
I mean we don't have a government in
Washington that has any interest in
standing up for us and saying you know
is this right or is this wrong our City
Council is you know backing away from
its ability to do oversight it's just it
and that's the really frustrating part
that these members of the community are
facing now is ok so we've proven here
this is happening we thought was
happening but now what and we're still
waiting about giving voice to those
those voices who don't get frankly
covered well in by us or by anybody was
a much better effect
and was a much more meaningful outcome
than you know what the NYPD thought I
mean frankly the NYPD's response to this
all has been yeah we spy on Muslims
you're welcome and but that's not like a
flippant joke they say we do this and
and I think Mayor Bloomberg is like has
said and when you go back and write your
stories remember that we're that we're
doing that and keeping you safe so
you're welcome yes peace yeah um I've
been covering the Syrian American
community here in New York for my beep
with my class and I used one of the
documents that was released as a part of
your series and while it was an invasion
of privacy it was helpful for reporting
I went absolutely a restaurant by
restaurant I went to every single place
listed you ate really well and I did
I've had so much on this but I I was
wondering what the next steps for your
investigation are because most of what i
found was the report stopped that every
single one of the places listed was
wrong that they said that it was syrian
owned and it was owned by someone from
lebanon it said this is where
palestinians gathered and the hookah bar
was full of people from yemen so I'm
wondering if you're doing any work as
far as the NYPD is not only spying but
they're bad I don't think they're going
back and correcting the record on that
we saw that you know over and over again
I mean some of the stuff we just had to
laugh at it even in the you know they're
singling out people for being suspicious
or a threat and they've spelled their
names six different ways in a report I
mean it's who are you talking about the
same person I mean it's just um stay
tuned uh more more coming
um you mentioned some anonymous sources
that spoke to you that felt guilty about
doing so I don't know not guilty I think
they felt introspective introspective
that BAM seriously I do think that I
don't think anybody felt guilty I think
they felt like 10 years later it was
okay that to look it did it did it work
and was it smart and I think that I do
want to make that distinction but I
don't think that that that's guilt okay
with my question would be did you ever
encounter any anonymous sources Muslim
officers who perhaps are in the process
of making you more information than
non-muslim officers we're Muslim
officers more willing to leak
information anonymous of officers um I
don't know I mean didn't really break
down that way for it I mean it's just
not something I really a willingness to
leak isn't sort of the calculation when
you do these things it's just this very
fluid process and you're talking to
people over a long period of time and
you know what becomes a conversation and
what becomes a you know my conversation
is your leak right like a leak is just a
conversation that you didn't want me to
have so I don't think I I guess I
couldn't be with a more willing to come
forward and no so this is this will be
our last question about New York after
that I invite you or to ask any question
were relevant to the stories of course
of the panel will have 15 minutes for
like a general Q&A yes peaceful I'm
actually quite curious about the CIA
they're quite a kg organization and yeah
sorry I understand write that one down
severe understatement sorry I was
wondering if what were their comments on
your story ah no comment I'm a bet they
did an investigation that's right they
did they open an investigation which at
the CA is actually kind of a big deal
they did an internal investigation and I
they there was a covert officer just
back from the Middle East who was
embedded at the NYPD one of the most
senior guys at in the CIA and he had
just started his tour of duty at one
Police Plaza a couple weeks before our
story ran and they pulled him home they
brought him they said we're not gonna
that's not the relationship we're going
to have a police department anymore and
they did an investigation into how it
all went down and they said look what
about inappropriate right there in the
first place and they said okay when it
started we don't we don't think we ever
did anything that qualified as domestic
spying but we recognize that that we
sent him there without the right
oversight without having it reviewed by
lawyers or without any rules and we kept
them there too long and we didn't really
could keep good tabs on what exactly was
doing but lesson learned we won't do
that again and this is of all of course
anonymous because they won't give us a
report thank you you're welcome